[Música]
economía aquí en directo América me
acompaña en el estudio Jorge Hurtado
Jorge muy buenas noches bienvenido
comenzamos hablando de ese reporte que
brindó el fondo monetario internacional
sobre América Latina qué expectativa hay
Santiago el fondo monetario
internacional prevé una desaceleración
económica en la mayoría de las economías
de latinoamérica la región crecerá
solamente un 1,7% en 2023 eso es menos
de la mitad que este año según el
informe perspectivas de la economía
mundial las causas son múltiples la
pandemia la Guerra de Ucrania la
inflación los problemas en las cadenas
de suministro el crecimiento en
Latinoamérica y el Caribe será del 3,5%
en 2022 y del 1,7% en 2023 los
principales frenazos económicos según
este organismo serán para dos economías
chile y Colombia chile será el único
país de la región en negativo y
mantendría una inflación al alza el
próximo año por su parte Colombia
pasaría de crecer
7,6% este año a sólo expandirse 2,2% en
2023 hay escenario favorable Sí para
Perú Ecuador Bolivia Paraguay y
Venezuela
hablemos también de ese balance que hizo
sobre la economía global precisamente el
fondo monetario internacional bueno el
organismo dice que los riesgos para la
estabilidad financiera mundial han
aumentado el organismo rebajo de sus
perspectivas de la economía mundial para
2023 Espera que crezca solo un 2,7% el
próximo año frente al 2,9 que habían
estimado en julio pasado el fmi de
tiempos difíciles también para la
economía global Pero espera que la
incertidumbre no cause un impacto
demasiado grande para la primera
Economía del mundo Estados Unidos esto
Gracias por supuesto a su sólido mercado
laboral escuchemos a Pierre Olivier el
es consejero económico del fondo
monetario internacional esto decía
en Estados Unidos el endurecimiento de
las condiciones monetarias y financieras
ralentizará el crecimiento hasta el 1%
en 2023 en China hemos rebajado la
previsión de crecimiento del próximo año
al 4,4% debido al debilitamiento del
sector inmobiliario y a los continuos
cierres la desaceleración es más
pronunciada en la zona Euro donde la
crisis energética causada por la guerra
seguirá pasando factura reduciendo el
crecimiento al 0,5% en 2023
Jorge en los próximos tres años el
precio de la vivienda podría caer hasta
un 25% a nivel general en el mundo
entero esto es una consecuencia directa
de la subida de los tipos de interés que
están llevando a cabo los principales
bancos centrales del mundo para contener
la elevada de inflación el fondo
monetario internacional en este mismo
informe advirtió que la subida de los
tipos podrían provocar que el precio de
la vivienda caiga en los próximos tres
años hasta un 10% en las economías
avanzadas y hasta un 25% en los mercados
emergentes el la misma afirma que muchas
economías avanzadas y mercados
emergentes pueden enfrentar estos
riesgos relacionados con el mercado de
la vivienda a medida que aumentan las
tasas hipotecarias y se endurecen los
estándares crediticios el aumento de las
tasas hipotecarias trae consigo un
aumento también en los costos del
endeudamiento y los estándares
crediticios se vuelven cada vez más
estrictos el fmi Alberto que las
quiebras de los promotores inmobiliarios
en China podrían extenderse del sector
al sector bancario afectando tanto a los
bancos locales como a los nacionales y
vamos a hablar ahora del presidente de
Estados Unidos Joe biden que propuso
redefinir a los trabajadores autónomos
en la economía colaborativa A qué se
refiere el mandatario bueno fue
específicamente a través de un
comunicado del Ministerio del trabajo de
Estados Unidos que afirma que el
objetivo de la iniciativa garantizar que
los empresarios no clasifiquen como
contratistas independientes a
trabajadores que no deberían serlo
dejándolo sin un salario y un horario
justo esta clasificación según el
Ministerio del trabajo ahí
conecta a empleados el sector de
cuidados servicios de consejería
camioneros repartidores de domicilio la
construcción y también la hotelería
ahora se abre un periodo hasta el 28 de
noviembre para que las partes
interesadas hagan sus comentarios sobre
esta propuesta del ejecutivo tras la
propuesta empresas como Uber Dash y Live
cayeron en la bolsa de valores y
hablemos ahora de los indicadores Cómo
les fue a las principales bolsas del
mundo el extender en Pure 500 y el
nasdac de Estados Unidos cerraron con
pérdidas en su quinta sesión consecutiva
mientras esperan el dato de inflación
que se va a brindar el día de mañana en
Europa la bolsa de valores de Londres
cerró con una caída del 1,6% después de
que el fondo monetario internacional
pronosticará una ralentización de la
economía del Reino Unido desde el 3,06%
de este año hasta el 0,3% para el
próximo y en Latinoamérica el índice es
en primer Val de la bolsa de comercio de
Buenos Aires cerró con un descenso del
5,29%.
es todo por el momento en la economía
Muchas gracias Jorge a continuación el
debate aquí en directo América
[Música]